[Music]
uh hi guys how's everyone doing today
hi guys
yeah hey i'm good are you i'm great are
you
very
dad
i'm pretty good pretty pretty feeling
good pretty pretty good uh by the way
just as an aside my favorite moment of
the super bowl was the larry david hand
that was really really good i don't know
what kind of like bitcoin that i just
bought but i really enjoyed it
nonetheless it was good larry david and
said yes
they said yes whatever the product is
um
so uh where do you guys want to start i
uh i think we've got some things to talk
about today
wait you want to start with super bowl
are we gonna talk about halftime and we
could talk about the halftime show were
you surprised that people didn't like it
no
and uh
i was i've been thinking about this for
a couple of days
um
it felt it the further away from it the
more it feels like a pretty important
moment
to me
um
am i surprised that people didn't like
it no
but i think the people who don't like it
and post on social media that they
didn't like it it says more about them
than anything else
and so you're gonna have to fill me in i
cannot believe i'm heading to berry
quarter to get the social media reaction
but
uh what what am i missing what is the
like the going complaint about the
halftime show uh
it was hip-hop
so
so a lot of older people don't like it
well a lot of younger people don't like
the who exactly exactly and if it wasn't
for the georgia land
i know but it was it was the first
not the first hip-hop uh halftime show
but it was the first big huge production
like that it was a pretty important
moment it was a pretty intentional
moment i thought
and i think it's being received that way
by a lot of people who grew up with that
music what do you feel like production i
don't know
what do you mean big huge production
i mean they've done that kind of large
production stuff yeah yeah yeah i meant
start to finish
entirely dedicated
uh to hip-hop and
in particular those
iconic
you know
characters that were part dre and snoop
and eminem i mean it was
i mean this is one of those things that
i'll be honest with you
uh if you didn't like it
i don't give a [ __ ]
exactly
exactly
i got some news for you this might
surprise you i didn't watch it
i'm stunned i cannot
but
for anybody that doesn't watch the super
bowl what were you doing
uh this will surprise you even more i
was watching golf
[Laughter]
the phoenix open
yes the waste management open yeah the
people's championship yeah they got
those they got those trucks
yeah those waste management trucks yeah
and that's actually what they tried to
hit into that's actually it's a new
course
but that's not happening while the super
bowl is happening
early on it was
yeah and then we just watched more golf
after that
it was there
to watch
there's like
just comes out and says it's so like
he's so surprised there's a golf channel
there's a there's a whole channel
so let me get this straight because i
know who did this it was your dad right
it was you hanging out with your dad and
so dad said no we're just going to keep
it on golf the rest of the day forget
the super bowl that's what he said he
went to the uh he was in the lounge at
the at the council fire at the golf
course
and he'd been there since nine in the
morning just sitting there drinking beer
and watching golf it was too cold to
play that's what he said and then you
know like four he calls me and he's like
hey what are you doing i'm like nothing
he's like oh you want to come over and
have a beer sure
so he called reinforcements in because
he'd been you know drinking there all
day uh-huh and and uh so then we stayed
until about seven or eight
yeah but at no point did anyone say hey
guys the super bowl's on we should at
least turn it on a few people did but
nobody wanted to watch it
wow
i'm stunned i don't know yeah i'm
stunned
if you if you'd have said you watched
the puppy bowl i would be less stunned
than you spent i'm stunned that i that i
watch that much golf
[Laughter]
although i mean let's be honest if
there's anybody in my life that is good
at this it's you and just having
something on and taco just being okay
with whatever it is that's true it
really doesn't really matter he's you
know what'd you say
he's a flow he's good goes with the
phone
oh yeah of course i'm drinking on the
old man's tab so yeah i'll have another
right over here thanks
i mean
you could you could be watching you know
barry swimming naked yeah and he would
be like yeah i'm okay with this so long
as yeah if there's is there beer if
there's still beer yeah i'll watch it
yeah
beer
was but it wasn't a pbr that's the
problem
no they have uh ultra though that's
that's pretty good
oh it is
yeah is did you do a taste test
challenge do you think you could uh tell
the difference between ultra and your
favorite beer of all time which is the
miller highlife well yeah at this point
i don't know my confidence is shook
i did have another high life i had
another highlight the other day and it
was pretty good so you know i'm still
happy with my choice
pretty good um
uh yeah i'm very surprised taco spent
the evening watching golf and not the
super bowl i just it's fascinating to me
to be in a um a sports complex which a
golf course is essentially but you know
you get all that you know male
energy and all the tvs and now one of
them happens to be on the biggest event
of the entire year oh i agree i mean
there's like 40 tvs in there and they're
huge it's like the whole wall is tvs
every single one of those on golf it was
all on golf yeah
what a waste
what a waste of time
[Laughter]
wow well you were hanging out with your
dad i'll give you that that's pretty
good yeah and he likes football but he's
more into college he doesn't really do
uh professional
but it's the super bowl yeah exactly i
don't know
i was surprised too i figured he would
have at least wanted you know turn it on
let's see what's happening no care well
um
well the halftime show was great i i had
no problem with it i thought it was a
lot of fun um i just think that it's
it's just part of the nomenclature at
this point that we all just hate
everything yeah you know it just no
matter what happens we have to hate it i
was listening to sports talk radio
um
i guess yesterday actually no it's today
and people were bitching and complaining
that the game wasn't good enough
right i mean this is how
like the recency bias of our world they
can't even like they need it to come to
some like
it needs to have a season-ending
cliffhanger or it needs to have a season
like a season-ending
big explosion like ozark does yeah
people just want to hate stuff and i
don't i don't really understand it and
i'll be honest with you barry i guess
maybe it's because i'm older or i just
have stopped caring but i don't even
listen to it anymore i don't even it
doesn't even oh it doesn't come through
my radar i come to i don't like any time
where that is just you know i look see
the people complain i'm like yeah okay
couldn't see that coming you know
especially from you or whatever
hated it worst one ever
okay is this mostly on facebook you
think
because that's where you spend the most
of your time yeah i spend more time than
they're there than the others yeah
probably yeah this is we gotta get you
off facebook
i guess
okay tell me which one that's where all
the boomers are
let's get to snapchat we'll start
sending some nudes taco yeah don't need
that
uh i wanna i wanna get into the uh real
quick the jack antonoff conversation
that
surprisingly blew up out of nowhere i i
didn't anticipate it getting as much
traction as it did but if you didn't
follow it we had a conversation with
jack antonoff from bleachers last week
and
afterwards by the way just as we don't
talk about this enough how well the
consequence of sound people
um do these write-ups and they spend so
much of their time and energy promoting
the podcast and they do such a great job
with it so
they did an incredible write-up of the
jack antonoff conversation and part of
it um they highlighted
a kind of i guess controversial moment
where jack antonov
sort of equated
uh damon alburn and his description of
taylor swift as a songwriter to be
trumpian
and i think that got a lot of attention
consequence did a great job with it then
it went to pitchfork rolling stone and
then all of a sudden m
nme
uh and every publication all of a sudden
now has the what podcast
um talks to jack anthony off and jack
canton off says blanket like it was it
was kind of interesting to watch but at
the end of the day i kept i kept
like trying to replay it in my head
and i must totally admit i didn't go
back and listen to it
i didn't ask him anything about damon
albert and taylor swift
yeah be one thing if you could claim boy
i saw that comment
i set him up for that one i put that
ball on the t didn't i yeah
i'll get the sound bite i smell it man
i am so good at this watch what happens
i will no i didn't even ask him about it
i i meant to bring up the whole point of
me bringing that up was because i wanted
to hear how ridiculous
some of his requests can be and i knew
he'd have a good one and it was barbra
streisand right well that was the whole
point and you know just to get there he
mentioned being literal and i thought
i'd throw in maybe i did it
subconsciously i don't even know but
all i did was mention
he talks about you know you either a
songwriter you're not and then i said
well i mean
if you're damon alburn
you think it's a very literal thing oh
well there you go yeah you did put it on
a t
i didn't expect it to be that
well
i mean i don't how would you
okay but here's here's the part that i
and i'm surprised you guys haven't
busted my balls about yet because
uh around here it's been around the
station it's been
a
big laugh riot on all brad guy's part so
if you go back and watch the video
right when
he says the most quotable part of the
interview right the news part of the
interview
he's doing his you know
you also should just shut the [ __ ] up or
whatever he says right
literally if you're watching the video
while he's saying the most newsworthy
thing you see this happened but i mean
but but you know what
i expect it from politicians i expect it
from
idiots and herbs and
[Laughter]
if this video finds its way i don't know
entertainment tonight or something
you're gonna see the city and radio
station go
i didn't watch the video i think i
listened to it
that's funny i'm now i'm going to go
back and
this is this is why you should subscribe
to the youtube channel you got to watch
the video if you're not watching the
video what happened was i guess i was i
was
i was rearranging my channels
rearranging my chair and i hit the lever
that sinks you down and all of a sudden
he's just talking to an empty screen
like i went down
that's a clown car moment of my life
and like in the middle the other thing
too and the only reason i i think
the guy that works here noticed it is
because during the interview you hear me
go
because i'm falling out of my chair
absolutely so stupid yeah there you go
oh so instead of brad's instead of brad
stinks it's brad sinks breadsticks yeah
right things
watch watch this guy that he's a great
interviewer watch him disappear whoops
he doesn't even need to be there
god he's good that's funny
um it was a good job though it was good
all the whole interview was good people
should go back listen that
was
very highly downloaded episode two
especially uh not just you know that
part but uh talking about super jam and
how much he loves bonnaroo and all that
i mean it
he says everything we've been saying for
five years
yeah i hope we didn't spoil his return i
don't know something tells me that uh
yeah he's not going back to that that
not come back
at 60 minutes that brad guy
can't even get a chair to work properly
that guy pulls stuff out we you didn't
mean to say i don't trust that idiot i
can't even operate a chair
um yeah i i was told that he would do it
again but now that i'm seeing the
reaction i i don't know if he's coming
back i don't know if he's coming back
and i really wish that he would because
he was actually i had so much fun with
the the conversation and
the other thing too that the other thing
that i i noticed was man it's just so
polarizing whenever you take
um
take sides or
[ __ ] on taylor swift it's one way or the
other right it is the most
she it's like kanye with her she is the
most polarizing as polarizing of a
person in the industry as you can find
so
believe me i've heard some stories about
her and what i what you don't want is to
have her pr people come after you
because um she's got a machine she has a
machine and they are on it you know i
was good i was gonna ask about that and
i i'm a i like her i i don't know a
whole lot about her what is the deal is
it just because she's so huge that she
becomes such a target i mean
i don't what has she done that makes her
you know such a target
um
well
first off i think that
if i could be fair because i don't want
to just come out and you know bash on
taylor because i do think that you know
there are some really good moments in
her career and a lot of things that she
should be celebrated for i think that
you know she's not been afraid of um
rocking the boat
and then we'll act like the martyr
afterwards as if why is everyone
attacking me as if she hasn't you know
literally thrown
she has she's had some debate
yeah i'll say i'll agree with that um so
you know with all that being said
she also
i think there was a there's a part in
the early part of her life where she was
sort of slut-shaped
and um i bet that she doesn't really
appreciate that too well
so no she doesn't really give a damn and
if you are as successful as she is why
would you give a damn um now you get to
roast anybody and everybody you want i
think it's the the sort of uh martyrdom
that she always seems to
to to lay on pretty thick with all that
being said
it is a pretty stroke of genius to have
your entire catalog sold out from under
you and then just redo it all yeah i
mean okay
like or not i mean that's a pretty i
just really i know is a lot of people
that i know and respect who i would not
have thought were taylor swift fans love
her because they love her they
their shows are great
and then i have a friend who is a
musician who defends her and says you
know first of all people need to realize
she pays the salary of a lot of oh yeah
oh yeah and for no other reason than
that you know leave her alone she's an
industry under herself so another one
that does that
and not people don't even know it
dave matthews is one of the most
is a giant in the industry now you may
think it's just some 90s band who's
going back on tour but if not for you
know dave matthews there's no ato or red
light there is no bonnaroo uh you know
the the umbrella that he has it's it's
unreal it's absolutely unreal and you
know she's really become sort of that um
you know there's only a few people in
this industry that that have that kind
of
sprawling type of
yeah you know stretch
sprawling type of
you know reach right ray
to back to the super bowl draping one of
them trey's got a incredible you know
platinum we're talking about
you know
dozens and dozens hundreds of people who
are employed because of these these guys
so yeah i mean it's not just a few so
look i mean and you don't see you don't
see jay-z or dre or
dave matthews taking as many shots as
taylor does um but with all that being
said you know there is
some insufferable
moments that you know she has you know
been in and you could probably chalk
that up to being a child and young and
um
you know who knows yeah you know or just
having that bigger spotlight put on you
i you know we all can sit here and say
what we think we would act like and how
we would act being that ginormous
don't know tell us you so yeah
um
i feel like there was something else
about the jack
interview that uh i wanted to bring up
and i don't necessarily remember what it
was and we did find out that it's 1984
all songs from 1884 i think we all could
just assume that but hearing him say it
was pretty cool right um had we had some
more time i probably would have you know
jumped into more bonnaroo talk to be
honest with you but we had such a
limited amount of time
and you know i had a good idea i had to
set up the t i had to you know set up
the damn album
somehow
you got what you wanted and got out of
there man that's pro the big uh the big
news that came down today
did you guys see what coachella said
no oh wow okay this just came out
earlier and if you're listening to this
on a different day you probably already
know but the news came out that
coachella was going to drop
all coveted regulations and restrictions
from
their festival in april
um but i don't know if
i can see a calendar in the calendar you
know it looks like april is uh january
february march two months away
and
they are already dropping all
restrictions so you don't need a
negative test you don't need a proof of
vaccine you don't need literally
anything for 150 000 people um
your thoughts barry anything
not surprised it feels like with all the
others what walmart did the same
it feels like we're heading that way
and what i think will happen is we'll
see that and then individuals will be
making their own decisions i mean i had
a couple of conversations just today
about people
another musician who canceled a local
gig he just doesn't feel right and yet
he was in a luncheon room with about 35
people
you know no mass one there's one mass so
i'm not surprised
uh well
i think of it like so mardi gras is
happening right now and we've been going
to parade after parade ball after ball
and there are moments where i feel a
little
you know a little
close a little tight so i'll put the
mask on and i you know
maybe it makes me feel better or
something right that's what i mean you
know but that is an open
air
open to
you know i haven't paid a ticket for it
i can just walk in and go home whatever
i want to the only thing about a
festival like this is that if you least
have a covid test or a
you know proof of vaccine at least
there's some sort of layer of protection
at least it feels like a layer of
protection you don't feel
weird about not having that
well i do that's what i'm saying but
it's a i it's an individual i think it
will become an individual
thing like you just said you feel weird
about it so you either put a mask on or
you back away or go home or whatever
um but i think the majority people are
just they're over it they're ready
they're done i'm not saying it's right
or wrong
i'm just saying that's definitely the
vibe i feel well that's that's the way
that i feel
you know i did i did everything that i
was supposed to do you know i've done
all my parts and at some point i've
gotta you know we gotta get out
as my uncle would say get out amongst
them go live um you know but it does
make me feel better when i go into a
restaurant and they're checking vaccine
cars it does make me feel better um
you know i think it would make me feel
better if there was some sort of layer
of of at least perceived precaution um
but you know the reality is that's
probably all it is is perceived probably
yeah it's i think it's mostly theater
i mean
how many how many people did we hand our
vaccination cards to at a restaurant in
new orleans and they just like okay yeah
fine i could have handed them a you know
an uno card or something yeah they don't
really care they're just okay
you know what you say that i did it
i've had that card six seven eight
months i think i've shown it one time in
that way well you're in a different
place though
i mean but it's my place it's whatever i
understand but i don't know anybody
like that city
has not acted as if covert was happening
since kovat began they don't they've
never pretended like this thing was a
thing here the rust has seen it
here you have to show it to get anywhere
which is strange isn't it because you're
you're in a city of disasters
yeah yeah
yeah
well they're not our disasters you know
but they're disasters and you've seen
all of them everything that locust that
i can think of oh i've dated a few i am
but russ i mean russ is right i mean if
he showed a if he showed a vaccine card
that had a penis drawn on it uh nobody
knows different yeah that's fine he'll
take it
pretty much i mean nobody's checking to
make sure that the name matches your id
and you know
but you know i'm happy to show it i'm
i'm proud that i got it you know it's a
lot to put on wait staff i mean it is
it's tough enough they got to check your
id and worry about that and now you put
this on them
and you know they've been yelled at and
screamed at and called everything so
i'm sure they're over it too i mean i
know that i'm not saying it's right well
i mean the other thing too that you know
not many people talk about is i mean the
state of california
you know
basically they're doing it because the
state of california has lifted the
restrictions here but you know it was as
one point the most restrictive state in
the entire country and there might be a
tad bit of politics happening
right now so coming up you know but also
at the end of the day you know it does
feel like the numbers are coming down it
does feel like this thing is is starting
to go away but every time that we felt
like that it just comes right back
yeah
again i'm not saying you're right or
wrong or they're right or wrong it's
just where we are um so
today we haven't even talked about this
yet but today uh we're gonna have a band
from nashville on coin i don't know if
you know coin coin's been to bonnaroo
before they uh uh got uh a couple of
you know really you know pretty good
hits including one i think is uh such a
fun song talk too much they're a great
live band uh we spent about 20 minutes
with those kids uh earlier last week and
you know i think that they're
they would have my first thought was oh
good we get to talk to some kids who
have never been to bonnaroo
and then i forgot that they were at
bonnaroo
yeah we're getting to the point barry
that you know 17 18 19 years in going to
this festival i've forgotten half the
people that i've seen
i'd be stunned if you
if it was different
i loved hearing the story of how they
got there
especially
the drummer was that ryan is that his
name
um
talking about it he told his parents
okay i'm gonna go next time i go i'll be
playing there that's pretty funny i mean
that's some joe burrow
um so we're going to talk to coin but at
first if you could because it really
helps us out uh it helps the consequence
people who have been so wonderful to us
the last year if you could rate and
review the podcast that would be uh
quite helpful um you know just takes two
seconds i don't know if you need to do
it again if you have already done it
before uh but you know start a whole new
account yeah i rate it from a whole new
account uh no raid and review it really
helps the uh the whole thing the whole
operation so
let's talk to coin afterwards i want to
talk about a bonnaroo ticket giveaway
on the what podcast
[Music]
my home life because of you guys is so
difficult do you know how often my wife
walks around saying you talk too much
every day of my life
i'm so happy that uh
what a beautiful accident yeah
i'm so sorry
somebody finally put it into words yeah
he wrote the theme song to my life yeah
unknowingly we're torturing you it's
beautiful yeah that's right you know it
it is pretty uh impressive to write a
hook that can be repeated every single
day for years and years and years later
yeah as an insult
if yeah so let's start here because you
you're talking to some fellow
tennesseans uh barry in chattanooga uh
russ and outside of chattanooga and i
left chattanooga two years ago um you're
right up the road in nashville let's
start at belmont
because um
you know for those that don't know
you guys met in college right
yeah around that yeah definitely
formative years
yeah joe and chase met in a music theory
class and then i was dating someone who
sat beside them who volunteered me to
basically go jam in chase's dorm room so
that's how the band started
i know a guy i think you should yeah i
think the word the word jam was
definitely used oh for sure yeah
at that spry age
yeah
is anyone using the word jam anymore by
the way nobody's i mean
no i think they use free trial
free trial
that's so good were you just looking for
you know somebody to
pre-trial with on weekends or were you
guys looking for a ban uh to put a band
together barry i'll be honest with you i
have no idea we were after
well that's what i wondered i mean yeah
i looking backwards i i really it was
we were um
had the expectations of um being the
biggest man in the world but also the
hope of absolutely nothing so
uh it was it was really it was a weird
time where like you know you know that
you want to make
you want to make songs that insult
people around the world and then you
also uh
you just you also have no idea what to
do what the next step is so i'm just so
glad i met these people and um it's
bizarre it's bizarre that like
essentially
fate led us to be like the i just can't
believe this is the same people that we
started the band with like i feel like
there's always some turnover yeah ten
years right
yeah
yeah was one of your early tracks brad's
hair is overrated
uh because that would uh it's the new
one cut me straight to the core
[Laughter]
did you go to school that always
fascinates me how people get together i
mean you hear about we put an ad in the
paper or put a poster up on a bar
but belmont's a pretty serious music
school
so you you obviously went there for a
reason was it
i mean you said you weren't looking to
start a band what were you thinking
career-wise that made you go to belmont
well i think each of us can speak to
this but uh i mean moving to nashville
was more of like i think we all saw it
as somewhat like serving as an incubator
for
our creativity and like it just felt
like fertile ground at the time and just
like the next logical step and not as
not as terrifying as la or new york
seemed at the time it was just like a
baby step forward and so belmont was for
sure just a catalyst for me to move
there and i think yeah
for joseph just getting to a city with
like-minded people and you know in a
place where just some kind of movement
was happening
and um but yeah belmont it was less my
dad was a songwriter
and so i always kind of saw it as a
possibility to play music and really do
it as a career it was never like insane
for me
um so with that was always beautiful i
have that
realistic element at my um
you know as a as an archetype
but uh so yeah
i can't put it into words i was not out
to start a band i just um had never
played music in front of people and
joseph and ryan had high school bands
and they were like you know what like we
know how to like do this kind of and
and iron sharpens iron and you know here
we are
when you guys were
like first writing do you you still have
some of those tracks do you still go
back to them what are you uh
what are you doing with those things
yeah honestly we put out we wrote four
songs because the goal of the band was
to play like just like one show to see
what happens i just wanted to feel what
that felt like and i had just recently
been to my first concert around that
time it was just like this seems like
um what a beautiful connecting
experience and i really want to
experience that for myself and like i
said they helped me but we wrote four
songs so we played our first four song
set which was
13 minutes soaking wet
and um yeah we actually put those songs
out and that that's kind of what
that's those songs led to we've actually
never not put out a song i don't think
that we've written that we've i mean
we've written a bunch now but like
around that early stages we just kind of
just kept putting out everything
whatever we had to date would get
released and then would help us have a
longer set list yeah
where was the show by the way
oh wow so was it a there was a magazine
that existed briefly in nashville i
don't think it does anymore i don't know
it's called native magazine and it was
their launch party
which is such a funny word but it was
and it was in this warehouse building
that sounded like a basketball gym so we
always joke that we played in a
basketball gym because it just sounded
like one so we had like a drum shield
and like we were like the loudest band
we were the first band and the loudest
the first band and the loudest band and
the shortest and i know we've all told
this story
differently about the same but one
detail we all remember is that the next
show we were offered
was by someone from a venue what was it
like 12th and porter or something like
that and they were like hey if you guys
can just play a little quieter like
we'll get you some gigs and we can you
can play next weekend if you want we're
like okay and i don't think we ever got
quieter but we definitely did the gig
and then one gig led to the to the next
so i guess it's some pretty lousy a r
advice to be honest with you
loud was like our genre
i want to ask joseph
and chase the uh when when uh ryan's
girlfriend
approached you did how many times
did she have to keep keep suggesting it
was it first time or it was the first
time i don't know because i wasn't there
it worked out well obviously i hung up i
ended up hanging out with ryan like two
days later yeah became buddies yeah she
just really overheard us talking about
starting a band you're like you guys
need a drummer
and uh just really volunteered the rest
of his soul for to us for the rest of
his existence i'm ten years in the
saddle at this point so yeah yeah it
worked out good that'd have been really
uncomfortable if you sucked
that'd be nice i mean no then we got the
free trial i feel like we all know
so
it was it was good it wouldn't work out
yeah thanks kristen i uh
oh yeah and you guys just decided the
fertile ground of nashville um i guess
proved proved uh
you know good for you you stayed
and you never decided to to bail why is
that
i mean
we we definitely chose we've moved away
and we've kind of it'll always be home
and it's always going to be roots it's
always going to be a relief for tour
from
but you know
i mean who knows who knows where we'll
be
forever but um we definitely love it and
it's it's always served us a reset so
even times we've spent so much time in
l.a or ryan moved to l.a joseph moved to
brooklyn for a while it's just it's
always that that means of just like
reset and come back to the roots and
it's
always serves as such a
such a wonderful homework for us
speaking of drummers barry i got news
this morning that uh one of our best
friends in the world jared from repeat
repeat had you on their podcast uh oh
recently yeah yeah jared's jared's a
good friend i mean i i've known him and
his wife uh since he was working at
burger up and i used to work on the same
street and i feel like we were just kind
of doing the scrappy you know part-time
job thing for a while and it's it's been
cool to watch him and his band flourish
and he's kept up with us too but yeah
they're they're great people you know i
i've known jared a long time i never
knew he worked at burger up
yeah that's how we met and he was like
he always would take care of me and be
like dude like when are you playing the
show and i was like i don't know why do
you play the show we had like a fun
relationship so he's a good guy
so
so when um
you get you get the the the the records
done you get the tours moving and then
you get the call from bonnaroo um that
first show that you did in 2017. talk
about that what that meant for you and
your career if it meant anything um and
what that
like that entry into festival world was
like
yeah honestly i i think at the time i
just it's so part of the zeitgeist
especially like in southern culture and
just america in general you know and i
feel like there's something about uh
whoa this like russ just showed up
what's up russ how's it going
he must have been here the whole time
[Laughter]
say hi to laura thompson
it's literally going to be on tombstone
i've been here the whole time
i like that um
but uh yeah there's something really
special about being from nashville and
being so close and almost like a
hometown show and and just to
participate in such a cultural moment
was uh really special and we're so glad
to be playing again this summer
along those lines let me i don't know
brad if you looked at their tour
this this this list for the next two or
three four months looks like somebody's
wish list
right i mean this is pretty sweet with
you guys going you got uh
you've got uh
uh where to go top of the list
harrisburg
oh of course yeah later this month let's
start there but then you go to dublin
belfast london
cardiff liverpool birmingham i'm
skipping some glasgow leads and then
you've got shaky knees for castle
governor's ball and then bonnaroo
it's not a bad summer
no and and a lot more to come as well
yeah yeah we're really excited we're
super grateful it feels like honestly
what you just said really resonates
because we used to look at band's tour
schedules and be like oh man that is so
sick hopefully we could do that one day
i know it is special it's crazy window
it's it's i appreciate you putting that
perspective because we've worked so hard
for this and you know you walk in by
inch and and you were like of course i
should be stronger than yesterday of
course i should do better than yesterday
but nothing's guaranteed and it's just
it's so cool to just take it and breathe
and um and realize that the songs we're
writing are resonating with people out
there and people are assigning their own
meeting and uh to them it's just special
when you when you said that monarch was
still part of the southern culture and
the zeitgeist had you been before
i had never been no
no i i had friends that started going as
early as like 16 and experimenting with
lsd and that sort of thing so i i was
from cleveland ohio and had a lot of
friends who did like the party let's go
to you know so you know nashville's only
like eight hours from ohio so i feel
like a lot of people would caravan down
but i actually remember and my mother
brought this to my attention but there
was a large group of kids going and i
remember i couldn't afford a ticket my
parents were like we can't afford the
ticket to send you down with them but
like and i i just remember saying
okay i'll just wait until i play it one
day which was such a stubborn thing and
it's such my personality to like set
that goal for myself but when we
actually played it i was like i told you
so screaming at yourself in the mirror
yeah yeah
which is funny we didn't even have a
mirror at the uh at bonnaroo the first
year i remember thinking that the
hospitality could be improved slightly
yeah see we'll see what's up
well if you ever talk to bishop briggs
the um the trailers that you stay in
they don't uh they don't hold up uh
because i basically destroyed it in a
matter of about 10 seconds just trying
to open a bottle the whole thing came
down and it's
you're right
it's one of my favorite stories ever she
she said just leave she finally said
justly
was she in it when it collapsed
oh yeah yeah we were all there i uh
ripped down the wall uh accidentally and
the whole thing went crashing down yeah
he tried to open a it wasn't a screw cap
so he tried to pop it on the side i was
doing the really impressive like manly
thing i'll take care of this for you
little lady and i went to open up the
bottle and as i did that the front of
the the
cabinetry came
crushing crashing down to the ground the
topaco flies across the room everything
sprays and literally after the the mess
of the day she just says
and then he did it again just leave yeah
and then he did it twice and that one
spun around on the ground that's when
she said just leave yeah hospitality
could uh
it couldn't improve a little bit um so
so now you have this this sort of world
you know jaunt that you have uh you come
back for the summer and barry went
through the the list for castle gov ball
bonner
shakinese i don't want you to pick one
but uh pick one
uh honestly i we're we're playing today
at appalachian state and boone north
carolina we're on the bus right now and
i i'm just as thrilled to be playing
here as anywhere and i'm just so
grateful for any time we get to play in
front of humans yeah as this thing
starts to normalize again you know
getting on a stage and having people
safely attend events whatever that might
look like we're just works we're like so
excited to play anywhere yeah
are the european shows much different
for you guys
we've only been there a couple times and
they've been super special um so yeah
they know you know the world is a
wonderful place
everybody sings along the same right
it's crazy hi uh i hope so yeah i'm
grateful for anybody showing up it's
great
that's really cool i uh i love i love
the new single i think that you guys are
um are
it feel it feels like you got like a
fast track it feels like there's a
there's a avenue for you guys when you
start to put something together that is
you know whatever the next step is
do you keep yourself in sort of like a
lane or
knowing where your sound is or are you
willing to to pretty much go
you know and make a jewette in the lion
and try you know let's try a hip-hop
song uh are you that far out of the the
lane or do you think that you've got
you're pretty in the pocket and you stay
exactly where you where you are
um
i mean somewhat someone of all the above
uh
it was we had a really interesting time
in 2020 with you know of course tour
getting canceled and i'm sure everybody
had a wild year but we just set out to
write as many types of songs as we've
wanted to write over the years and kind
of
instead of letting that our influences
creep into our our music and the way we
see it we just embrace
and fully jumped into you know
being it's like just
paying homage to our inspirations and so
we were able to get out a lot of
a lot of things that would have
otherwise been kind of
squirrely to put into into our songs
so by getting out a lot we i think that
it was such a good period of time when
we were able to really experiment with
things and and really hone in on what we
love to do and what brings us the most
purpose
so uh no we don't have a lane other than
to um
to do what feels right and um
you know give the song the uh the love
it deserves somebody told us one time
that a song each song is a busy universe
and yet if it needs more trees it needs
more trees it means more oxygen needs
more oxygen and so you give the song
what it needs and then stop like
questioning with the confines of what
does the album need what does it feel
more like coin whatever these constructs
you create for yourself just give the
song the love it needs and then
everything will work out you don't have
to put it out you know but
i think it's so important to fully
realize these things but you're going to
put it out anyway
i mean we'll see because you put
everything up
no no right that was a long time ago we
probably looked at 300 songs over the
past two years okay we're going back to
that that first chase when we asked what
you the plan was when you put the band
together and you said you had no plan is
it and 10 years later now you're still
very much together and we talked about
all the great stuff
now do you guys sit down and and talk
about the
future of future albums or is it very
much so yeah yeah we are very very
intentional then huh very intentional
and a lot of a lot of vision planning
and
goals and um
like responsibilities and assignments
and uh i don't want to say you run like
a business but you just have to be yeah
like you said intentional and very
careful with
um i've been very convicted by the
amount of like love and and um that
people have for
for this music
and i want to do what's best buy it you
got to be just trying to respect it
well i i wish you guys all the success
i'm excited to see at bonnaroo i i'm
excited to see how the show has has
developed and expanded and uh you know
i'm just glad to know that it stayed
loud
yeah that's it
thank you yeah we're excited too we'll
make sure that uh we start building the
dressing room now so that it's sure yeah
reinforce everything
structurally sound plastic cups go with
plastic cups yeah padded walls for me it
makes things a lot easier
thank you guys so much thanks guys so
much so glad to meet you and we'll see
you we'll see you very soon thanks guys
see you soon bye
[Music]
there you go the kids of coin on the
what podcast which bands this year that
matter barry porter lord taco brad
steiner so um i know i mentioned this
before uh but before we get to the the
actual ticket giveaway
i think that we're gonna
have one of my favorite artists in the
history of mankind on next week uh if we
can make it work barry um
i and got the biggest man crush on brit
daniel from spoon
so if we can get it on next week uh the
new album is absolutely incredible
lucifer on the sofa it is not even close
my favorite album of the last year uh go
listen to that because uh bret daniel
britt daniel from spoon on the podcast
next week
nice very cool
do you even know daniel do you even know
anything about this man not as not as
much as you because
if you
would i would appreciate
you doing a little
research on brit daniel look at him
check out his pictures
and then realize that he looks exactly
look at him and realize he looks exactly
like nick turner
oh nikki t nikki d hates when i bring
this up but him and the spoon guy look
identical does he talk like nikki t uh
no no a little bit more uh understated
but uh i think nick more understated
than nick
yeah i think nick purse
specifically grew a beard so he would
not look like brit daniel anymore he
does look like nick t i know
he doesn't look like me all these
incredible transitions that you hear on
the show they are of uh nick's
incredible incredible band um we'll put
the link up to check out their
soundcloud and their their spotify uh
here yeah and on youtube i'll put up a
picture of nikki t and uh britt daniel
next to each other see if people can
pick pictures
which ones yes yeah um
so
i have got a possibility i i need to
make total sure but i'm 99 sure we will
have tickets uh for the festival again
this year like we do each and every year
so this is our
yearly um
show meeting where we discussed
literally on the show how we're going to
give these away that will end up being
something really standard that we do
every year
uh so
consider this our promotions meeting how
are we giving these things what well
we've tried to give them away for the
last two years and it keeps getting
canceled yeah
yeah poor jack jack i can't imagine
oh well maybe she'll win again this year
uh
but still still not hearing any ideas
yet what do you want to do an essay
an essay
yeah i like that you know you know what
we could do actually because we've never
done it before um
we should come up with some sort of like
graphic design thing something that that
makes you creative and you have to whip
up something uh graphically for the show
i like it
okay i like it something
about our show or about bonnaroo well
i mean let's be honest
it's about us
okay i like it much better you're
getting there i like it
yeah i just remember when something's
creative about it i remember when um we
gave away at my old radio station we
gave away alabama shakes tickets was it
out of shakes tickets or shaky knees or
something like that
i had like 200 people make pictures of
me and brittany howard it was just me
and her photoshop so it's like me and
her
where is it like mccartney's head off
and my head on paul mccartney's body and
me and her jamming together
that's funny
when cher came uh to chattanooga many
years ago the paper at the paper we did
a contest where we
drew a car uh like a cut out share and
people had to
uh make their own fashion
cutout thing like that oh that's cute
like there's real magazines yeah yeah
yeah it was awesome you mix and match
hats and skirts and all that for the for
the kids listening magazines were these
paper publications that you would read
on a weekly basis
yeah they're from the 1900s
[Laughter]
so is barry yeah exactly i like this
this is a good uh this is a good it's a
good start maybe you know
we can do it that exact thing barry
and on either socials or the site taco
we give people available pictures that
they can use
taco's beard and put it on my face
through your face or something that'd be
kind of funny if anyone touches my hair
[Laughter]
i was waiting for you to go there if if
you want to win
stay away from the hair stay away from
there
um all right there you go anything else
we need to get to this week
no i don't think so uh looking forward
to your interview next week and we'll
have jeff quayle on sometime soon i'm
very much looking forward to that he's
always great uh
you know he's changed jobs so maybe we
can get him to give some
inside history of bonnaroo and festivals
in general he's oh he better let it all
out yeah yeah spillers i mean it's not
like he's under some sort of nda anymore
yeah let's go
i know he's but uh people spill it if
you listen to our show before you know
jeff he's been on a couple of times he
knows festivals and he knows the
industry and very excited to talk to him
so we got a lot of stuff coming
uh as a very wise man once said we got a
lot of things
all right look taco berry corner brad
we'll talk to you next week on podcast
bye
[Music]
[Music]
consequence podcast network